un dégât d'eau survenus dans cet
immeuble de l'île-des-soeurs entraîne
les résiliations de 36 beau et
l'éviction de dizaines de personnes et
locataires ont jusqu'au 27 octobre pour
se trouver un nouveau logement
une situation qui est loin d'être
évidente dans un marché où il ya pénurie
non non j'ai pas j'ai pas un endroit où
aller l'actuel les parfois inévitable
que certains travaux majeurs en train d
éviction mais des travaux souvent
cosmétiques serve d'excusé pour
expliquer des locataires rappelle québec
solidaire et utilise le motif des
travaux majeurs alors que leur seul et
unique but si de gonfler le loyer au
delà de la capacité de payer des
locataires qui habitent là parfois
depuis de très nombreuses années
on parle alors de rénovation lui ce
qu'il veut c'est transformé la maison
pour les nouveaux riches à venir
caresmel me le dis je ne pourrai jamais
me retrouver un loyer à ce prix là avec
ma course ça va être des 2,3 me suis pas
capable de paysans c'est ce que je fais
par mois c'est absolument invivable moi
je prends des anti-dépresseurs vous ne
la boue du pétrole ceux qui ont quitté
leur logement se sentent floués viennent
finalement il n'y a pas demandé de
permis pour agrandissement aux divisions
il les aurait neuf et sommairement il
s'apprête à les relouer pour les
associations de locataires les travaux
d'urgence ne devrait pas entraîner de
résiliation du bail
moi ça me paraît une tactique pour se
débarrasser de ses locataires eux qui
payent un loyer plus faible que la
moyenne ou qui veulent juste pas mort
algérie et à verser des indemnités aux
locataires du comité logement et québec
solidaire réclame un moratoire sur les
évictions et des amendements au code
civil pour mieux protéger les locataires
ici michel marsolais radio canada
montréal